hello vlogging camera guess what we're
gonna do with you Vlog this week it is
Sunday night and I'm editing the Vlog
that I've taken this week and realized
that I hadn't introduced it in any way
that makes actual sense so this is that
attempt to do so I had chemo round two
this week and I thought I would Vlog
before and after the experience to just
show you a little bit of what it's like
doing okay right now currently waiting
for Pizza Hut to get delivered so not a
bad Sunday night we're a bit frazzled I
got this hat does that look good yeah
this looks scream sound mind sound body
I'm very Rusty with vlogging switches
between this camera and my phone
apologies I'll get back in the saddle
but enjoy this little uh snippet of the
last week chemo round two and a crush in
this cancer here we go
[Music]
good morning it is Sunday so today we're
redoing Elliot's office last night we
painted it blue which was curious to
come in this morning and see if it
looked like absolute and it didn't
what a delight and so now we're gonna
bring stuff in and make it look
different than it did before
[Music]
don't mind my laundry it adds to the
chaos that's happening currently we just
took a shower and we decided to do some
self-care on a Sunday this is my version
of an extraction facial this is probably
um horrific to some dermatologist or a
face girlies out there but this is what
I do sometimes when I feel like my pores
need to be unclogged tell me a better
method oh going and getting a facial
yeah I suppose but what if you don't
want to do that am I genius or am I
Madness or are they synonymous
okay bye it's Monday night no it's not
it's Sunday night Sunday night I'm doing
one of the most difficult things I have
to put a duvet cover on that blanket
it's so hard why is it always so hard
it's 8 30. this is impossible
do you ever have like a day that is open
and that is so exciting because you
think about all of the cool things you
could get done that are both productive
creative nourishing to your soul into
your productivity and then you just sort
of toil and like do none of it and then
feel bad start to get hard on yourself
about it and then be like oh you
shouldn't be hard on yourself and then
you're like now I'm in this dialogue
that's where we're at today I wanted to
do so much writing today it's 4 P.M I'm
gonna do some writing but I just sort of
like geeked around today what did I do I
vacuumed I journaled about
around that's probably okay good maybe
hello I'm at therapy well I'm in the
parking lot going to therapy I got here
early so now I just awkwardly sit in my
car and try to fuss around like I'm
doing stuff before I get out and go
there's a parking attendant helping
someone Park Tuesdays we go to therapy
have fun let's think about everything
we're going to talk about before we go
in and talk about it let's plan out the
entire conversation right now right
that's what we're working on we're back
oh tear stains therapy obviously went
great well those are the little cries in
and now we get to go on with the rest of
our day with our brain feeling better
and just our tear stained sweatshirt on
display we love mental health we love
working on our mental health do you
think Gaga had to get on the nerd Tech
OTC because when her in that I fell off
the stage at our show in Vegas oh my God
can you believe I was getting refills
when that happened okay so now we're
back home and in an hour and a half I'm
gonna go over to memory so we're gonna
podcast for the week I usually sit down
and try to find things online to
podcasts about and I ask you guys on
Instagram and I'm going through all of
your suggestions I actually do go
through your suggestions every week
looking through and someone had said
that they were about to go get their
first mammogram and they were really
scared and did I have any advice I was
really scared when I went to get a
mammogram from many a variety of reasons
the actual like physicality of like what
are you doing how do you prepare for it
and then the emotional side of like oh
my God am I gonna find out something
really bad my advice is that it's really
not as scary as you think it is
hilariously awkward there's tons of
information online I've Googled like how
long does it take what happens because I
really didn't know other than I think I
saw someone say one time about how your
boob gets squished during a mammogram
but that's really all I knew and that
could really mean anything squished by
what human hands machine what goes on my
experience was going to this room with a
professional that is operating this
machine and they are usually now that
I've done it like twice they are very
professional and they are trying to get
you in and out the body has to contort
around this machine so your boob sits on
a tray and this other tray flattens it
so it can be actually photographed in
the right way and they might need to
maneuver your body around in different
ways so just be prepared that it's
awkward and that's how you know it's
going well I guess all you have to
really prepare to do
is to be naked from the waist up and a
bit awkward with another human being in
a room whose job it is to professionally
handle this situation my body my nature
is awkward in general and this actually
kind of spoke to my strengths because
you have to contort your body awkwardly
and I was like wow this is what I do
naturally so maybe
this is my time to shine I didn't say
that out loud I was totally silent the
whole time I really for went making
small talk I decided beforehand that I
didn't have to and I didn't want to
trouble myself with it I just wanted to
get this done so that's also another
thing you just need to get in there and
get out of there what happens after the
mammogram I can't really prepare you for
other than consider all the options I
guess but don't let that fear of what
you could find in a mammogram stop you
from getting a mammogram because the
other reason I turned on the camera just
now is that I wanted to mention an
article that I saw Taryn Southern
talking about and Taryn has been such an
incredible resource of wisdom and
experience she was diagnosed with breast
cancer stage three like four years ago
and has given me so much support and
information which has been amazing and
she was posting about this Washington
Post article about the rise of breast
cancer diagnoses in Millennial women it
is surprising and it's important to
spread this information because
Millennial women are at an age group
that isn't necessarily encouraged yet to
get mammograms or get tested because
technically they are younger than the
age that the medical world considers
um higher risk for breast cancer so like
out of breath had so much information I
wanted to get out there there are more
diagnoses happening so it is truly
important for you to check yourself out
see what's going on Nooks crannies bump
slumps and if anything is even a little
bit suspicious to you even a little bit
go to a doctor and bring it up and get
checked get a mammogram advocate for
yourself especially if you feel like
something is off and a doctor writes it
off because you are too young do not be
afraid to advocate for yourself a peace
of mind is
invaluable that's my midday the
information for you I also have to use
the restroom I thought about using it
before I started talking but I thought I
could get through it and now I gotta go
okay okay oh I got someone joining us
just got back from memory suite
podcasted and it was so fun I didn't
take any vlogging footage I meant to and
then I forgot but like here's a
reenactment
now I'm home it's like 5 30. tomorrow we
go for our second round of chemo and I'm
excited and nervous too I know more
going into it this round and knowledge
is power which is great but also there's
still the unknown so I thought I'd show
you how I pack up my chemo bag I bring
everything I can think of with me
because I'm a person that loves to nest
with my things literally as if I'm
packing to go to an Airbnb for the
weekend this is the bag I use I love
this bag so far cow pack
travel brand we haven't here from last
time comfortable socks women who run
with the Wolves still haven't read this
book yet notes on a nervous plan all of
our digestive candy lemon candy numbing
cream for my pool I got these bamboos
compression socks yes I did use that
this might get weird podcasts discount
code belly Welly I got hooked on these
um they're on Amazon this is fudge
brownie they're like more gentle on your
tummy for all my IBS girlys out there
liquid IV with symptom diary for my eyes
only and the doctors I've been tracking
all my symptoms
this is full of diarrhea good morning it
is 5 58 A.M
it's time for chemo day too we're making
some coffee we're in a comfy no pants
today's fit
cute comfortable makes an appropriate
statement for the matters at hand today
[Music]
thank you
I said Burr it's cold in here
[Music]
we're halfway through I've made the
nurses laugh a few times with some
squawky small talk is going excellent
[Music]
this pack does not smell like urine
so chemo is done infusions are done we
just have to wait for this cold cap to
cool down
six minutes left and then we're done
round two
[Music]
officially done session two just got my
cold cap off looking
glamorous you did it we did it this is
so zoomed in we did it we did it pack up
all of our stuff and get out of there
hooray okay look at this fun friend
looks like it's not going anywhere for a
while we're back from chemo my hair
looks stunning like the older brother
from Boy Meets World got stuck in the
rain we're back from chemo day two
session two and I feel great this is
always the weirdest part is that you
feel really amazing right after chemo is
done or the infusions rather are done
and then we
wait for the days that it sucks it's
cute so technically round two has just
started today but it was a great round
too everyone was so sweet I think I made
the nurses laugh a couple times hell
yeah Elliot said I was a delight we're
really going for an A plus score in
treating breast cancer and part of the
score is being a delight to others also
oh my God people have been sending me
really so many kind thoughts and so many
sweet things that I'm not great at
receiving like gifts
um and specifically gifts that are like
so thoughtful our friend Nathan who also
works with Tyler but and I know loves
the this way get weird podcast Nathan
thank you for listening drop this gift
off at my house the other night he knows
that on our podcast I mentioned that
during this chemo process as I get like
more kind of
weak and I have to stay at home that I
was worried that I'd probably become a
Disney adult because it seems like a
very safe fantasy world to enter in
times where you really can't do much
else and so he's a Disney adult and got
me like really sweet Disney specific
things look at this plushie that is
Goofy oh my God Nathan thank you a
really good day today it was a really
good day today you always wake up
nervous about you always I've done this
twice now and both times I've woken up
nervous so yeah I always wake up nervous
hoping that everything goes okay and
everything so far has gone okay and now
we just see how the rest of the days go
but today was great
yeah good morning it is 7 10 a.m after
chemo day two I slept a little bit which
is exciting I woke up at 6am the
steroids they got me up I'm writing down
my symptoms and my symptom diary that's
hilariously covered in like olive oil
stains which make it look like it's
infected in and of itself finishing a
sensible English Muffin breakfast and
Elliot woke up with a really painful eye
so we're gonna go to Urgent Care before
we go back for infusions is how
Securities is crumbling down pretty
quickly he picked a good day to have
something wrong with his eye because I'm
still full of steroids I can do things
today so let's see if we can handle all
that
foreign
[Music]
we're back from emergency care and the
patient is doing some of his favorite
things eating a bit of McDonald's
watching a bit of Sam Cedar he's gonna
be okay guys he's gonna make it he got
some eye drops he's gotta put him on
four times a day and you gotta eat your
little McDonald's breakfast and watch a
little squawky-talkie heads I'm gonna go
lay in bed for a few hours
I still have a needle hanging in my arm
I'm gonna go back over to the infusion
center in a few hours and do hydration
day wow what a fun morning already
fun look there he is
ah
I am a wrist hey we are driving over to
hydration I am Sons Elliott Morgan he is
dealing with his eye and I can do this
by myself because I'm a big Brave girl
and it's really not too complicated I'm
gonna go get a shot and then sit for two
hours with an IV in my arm again and get
hydrated and then sit in some traffic on
the way home that's how it's supposed to
go off we go big Brave girl we're
getting hydration
whole room to herself
what's your house with
and just like that we're done with
hydration and we're gonna head home I
had to get a shot in my butt today that
was a surprise always keep me guessing
wow a nice nurse named Tom gave me a
shot of Lupron in my ass
this old cancer thing just gets better
and better
yep that's how we're feeling today good
morning it is Friday morning it's about
10 a.m I've been up since 6am not doing
too bad today just tired I'm in bed
watching Project Runway got a thrilling
day ahead big incredible things going on
I'm gonna take a shower I'm gonna try to
I still have cold cap hair since
Wednesday so that should probably
attempt to be cleaned also I'm gonna try
to write a patreon post every Friday I
write a little blog on uh this make it
weird patreon and it's like a little
like journal entry kind of personal I
look forward to doing it we'll see if I
feel up to it today but so far so good
I'm not gonna push myself just gonna
chill I love bed so much so we're gonna
just do bed for a little bit okay good
news is we did a shower and it felt
great other news is
um yeah some shedding has begun today
this is all totally expected but it is
still a little strange it's really not
too bad but um it has begun this is what
we've been preparing for so we're really
in this kind of cool a sign that we're
moving forward into this stuff I should
brush my teeth I'm looking down at all
my fun mouth sore oral rinses and
realize I haven't done those yet hello
little Vlog hello I'm in my favorite
spot look at this little fetus head
coming at you fully swaddled on a
Saturday morning how's it going it's not
going bad actually it's going fine
well I'm just tired I'm so fatigued I
thought I knew what the word fatigue
meant and I didn't but now I do I went
to bed at like 7 30 last night and woke
up at 7 30.
this morning and guess what this is all
we're gonna do today and I went back
through my symptom diary from the last
round of chemo and Saturday of the last
round of chemo was way worse I was
having a lot worse symptoms glad I
marked that down we're just gonna stay
swaddled on a Saturday hey hey and
that's the update folks oh hair is
falling out a little bit here and there
nothing like Crisis crisis so that's
happening slowly and that's okay
honestly
I'm a little too tired to be that
concerned with it right now his swaddled
head's gonna go back to bed
see ya oh I'm gonna put you on a thing
it is Sunday look I have hair still big
moves today one big move I'm on the
couch instead of the bed oh I am
fatigued less tired than yesterday but I
am fatigued so today guess what we're
doing another day of this just sitting
and letting our body heal itself so far
we have brushed our teeth brushed our
hair washed our face put some
moisturizer on put some deodorant on
that's incredible stuff good job me
that's where the bar is at today
um Cancer's crazy if I mentioned that
literally a week ago I was moving
bookshelves in Elliot's office and now I
don't want to lift a thing and it really
is like waves it's just waves waves of
nausea waves of emotion waves of like I
Wanna Be where the people are and then
being like there's no second way I can
be where the people are I'm being
totally fine just like being couch
submitting like you really just gotta
submit and that helps you feel a little
bit in control foiler you're not in
control I do think I have a better
handle on this round of chemo than last
time but man I feel like I am in slow
motion I've heard people describe like
it feels like you are walking through
pudding I get it now you just feel like
a goober like a total goober so that's
where we're at today that's the update I
might vacuum today just so I can get
some steps in okay that's the update
thank you and you're welcome see you
next time I turn this on